[Music]
hmm yeah I got a compliment the butcher
man she put on [ __ ] gloves and then
she blows him away
a girl's lip was bitten off by her
ex-boyfriend Oh see this is [ __ ] thing
I'll tell you because crazy girlfriends
we do I think this is a donald glover
bit but it's so true it's like crazy
girlfriends we do crazy stuff but crazy
boyfriends they'll kill you it's true
you don't hear about that because now
it's a sad story you know let you'd be
like all the [ __ ] crazy but like when
he's crazy ain't good yeah that ain't
good at all so did we do that thing on
JK news we did it on JK news where the
guy was beaten the [ __ ] out of his
girlfriend and she went to the vet right
she went to the vet to go check on the
pit bull know what happened and so she
so basically he hadn't locked up in the
place for a while who's beaten the [ __ ]
out of her and she was like well we
should go well cuz we oh yes
and then she stood the note to the vets
when we got the cops and he had a gun on
him
yeah and then he had the gun Lobo hole
right in his [ __ ] dick waist right
there carry my [ __ ] dick on the waist
so it's like this I'm like that's not
reassuring the officers like you have to
go to mystic ways yeah you have to ride
of their dick - waist where your nutsack
I'm sure there's a dick chef and the gun
chef holster and gun tell me you had
your gun in your dick waist like they
just continually keep repeating dick
ways I can't believe it a gun in his
dick ways yeah subject with a dick waist
be careful I've seen a gun hold that
again dick waist well is that again
video dick waist or million make it an
Xbox gamer tag dick ways it's by
available marks camera tag that sounds
like why you can you don't like the kid
you never wanted your dick waist will be
blind oh my god I would cry at that
insult well you know what your dick
waist oh my god pissed you off like just
your dick waist community I'm gonna call
somebody dick ways that something yeah
we went over there this too like dick
waist mmm that was good you in salt
we're using it now all right so you guys
could use it too I hate to kill the mood
here but this one is a sad story so uh
Cayla horse Kayla she's from South
Carolina
hmm and are you guys that's why I tell
you it's sad because you have to try all
right so she started David look at all
this defensive we're a couple of cowboys
in the saloon right now we got the empty
we got guns on at the table mornin good
[ __ ] tongue thing though I got too
thick an actual toothpaste right so
Kayla she's from South Carolina she
started dating Seth in 2016 when he was
21 is she was 17 she broke up with him
after almost a year because he treated
her like property and then after like a
few weeks after they broke up she met up
with him so that he could write his
wrongs before he joined the Navy okay
and but then that's when he became
violent after she refused to get back
with him he tried to kiss her and then
like Kayla she pulled away he bit her
bottom lip so hard that it almost
completely tore off ohh
remember we actually did an article
would do bit her whole [ __ ] front and
mouth oh yeah and she was like really
pretty and blonde right yeah I remember
that
that [ __ ] was crazy man did he heal up
and chat it was good I think okay so the
follow-up cuz I read that article I
think I watched else video sorry so I
followed up on it later to read about it
and like it was like girl whoever face
but not speaks out and like now she's
dating a guy that's not very
good-looking
so no tan yeah basically the whole with
no teeth that should be so funny you
cannot have teeth that's all her tinder
sheets she's settled down with a real
like humble looking dude and now she's
like an advocate for like you know like
relationship violence and stuff but this
dude he's 20 21 23 when she was really
young oh that would be super insecure
that guy hate that guy super insecure oh
yeah yeah
a couple here Kayla and Sean or is it
Aaron toys a chartered well he's tall
yeah yes that's the bad guy yeah oh my
god there's so much blood out how did
she have enough time to do that I would
never do well Cox are they taking a
photo when they got oh my gosh yeah were
they but every catch it yeah this is a
[ __ ] crazy dude so y'all said
something why'd you have to go all the
way we know nothing
granted we know literally nothing we
know maybe negative things they just
don't even make sense
this one's canceled can they go back to
that picture which one why were those
[ __ ] it doesn't even make sense
Phillip DeFranco is gonna talk about
this one we need to talk about the JK
news stitches video no no no we're not
making fun of her though at all it was
just a surprise then agreed maybe okay a
big surprise cuz I was expecting to see
like the stitches here if they had to do
what if they did a full round to do it
cleanly and they were like scars will
fade like we have procedures to make
scars fade so it's better to make the
lip look as clean as possible and take
care of the clay you're like what
Ben was the surgeon was like they
thought it was asserted to make a bigger
smile can you go back to the injury
Louie Rowand cuz Andrews here so why is
it over here it was probably like inside
so I get this okay I get this okay it's
all right all bottle of wine because
what I was thinking was gonna happen was
they were gonna go from here so that it
could hold and then they could stick oh
wait what if it had something to do with
the lip being responsive with the rest
of the face you're so smart
really cuz like when I see this picture
her lips applying but all of the skin
has to match together so maybe it's like
if she smiled or something like not and
wouldn't like it wouldn't match up with
it so I'm saying we don't know the
muscles or nerves oh it's just the
bottom lip we don't know how much of the
damage the nerves like if nerves start
here maybe they were like we can give
her full feeling in her lips and if we
don't do this then she wouldn't by the
way we're not laughing at her at the
surgeon just yeah like we just threw us
off guard I think that's what it was
cuz I'm laughing at the surgeon who did
the operation and I just picture this
like [ __ ] really drunk I you know I
mean so that's what I was like good boy
what if it's like them they're yeah yeah
that makes sense but it looked like the
surgeon pictures if it was this right
and then she switched it and I wasn't
expecting that
yeah yeah I think you guys made me laugh
harder than what he says here's your
book like it's the same stick the
baseball go to the other one we've been
filming for a long time that's in clean
stitches though yeah that guy was
talking about so this is what she looks
like now oh really good
you're right well I mean there's a
tourism there but you know what it's her
smile she has a full she can actually
smart yeah she can smile wow he's like
maybe when she's if they didn't do that
then maybe when she smiled your side
wouldn't be responsive it looks awesome
yeah yeah like he did it on purpose
because he was like I want to leave you
with the mark for the next guy like hey
what did you do so he pleaded guilty to
assault and battery of a high aggravated
nature and he was sentenced to 12 years
in jail hell yeah yeah now he got a mark
on his record and can't legally get a
man that loves her she's actually dating
someone now who helped her through this
whole thing
hell yeah Kayla yeah yeah so oh yeah
she's so cute little dimples it's also
hurt with your new boo oh yeah yes yes
little Budweiser boy love her love her
we're team Kayla here yeah she looks
happy though - yes and we're all happy
that she can smile yep
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]